welcome to this video playing
grandmaster mega jet let some song
what's the name
sour Seungyeon from Australia okay um
it's a bit cool to play the Kings Enya
it's always strictly against GM's to
play this opening if you don't really
know it like I do
I am I have some knowledge but they all
have their their special enter anti
doubt and this means it's kind of an
uphill struggle okay this guy has played
them is played by Venetta tech with
before they played with a five this is
more of a prophylactic way to play it
trying to keep them Queen sites closed
maybe going for somewhat somewhat slower
counter play
we get this Bishop to exchange that and
from age six I thought that okay why
can't I take it anyway okay so normally
yeah it's got Queen age six maybe F for
coming
hmm that's a maybe possible
let's see this is not the type of Kings
Indian where I can play at five F for
and made him he will have from far too
much count to play and I could Bishop d7
trying to just take this night off
yeah I still wanted to take it
maybe Knight f6 thanks camel to play
against before
yeah his ideas that after I kept showing
a five is good night and Knight to c6
coming
which looks a bit annoying to say the
least
dad do I have some play with Knight to
f4 I guess I still have to take it I
don't really know if I want to allow a
six seven this is doctor 86 looks far
too problematic okay
knight c6 I should I should try to get
this this counterclaim maybe you can
just play this yeah exactly
96 I can take III at them for the moment
oh that's not very good disposition
Quincy sounds very passive move
it's just not good what can I do
he's got 96 anyway yeah this was just a
very bad position right out of the
opening as I mentioned the King's Indian
is a very risky opening if you play it
against a better player and you don't
really know what very well it can easily
lead to this to this kind of this kind
of this kind of very one-sided game not
saying that the opening is bad it's just
that it's it's very difficult to play if
you are not 100% yeah you're not an
expert
yeah much not much that I can be well
always has those checks also Queenie six
yeah unfortunately I'm not really
threatening anything even though they're
force it's not doing much right okay I
need to play a move
maybe rook da de threatened not he does
not have a check time warning
yes probably multiple ways to exact them
to win it
check
maybe I can at least shock him a little
bit
Jack that's Ruby singing it's not not
entirely pointless Jack but the points
bonds are a very very hard one so okay I
have a quitter saying max weakness just
singing her designs it was lost in any
case I guess even if I take him the
pawns are still too strong
I still too strong yeah this was a
really a bad position
I probably yeah my mistake is I can I
should not take on on b5 this is a this
is a mistake quite clearly how should I
play I mean I can just take which it
should be playable at least I mean it's
not like I'm enthusiastic about this but
it should be okay computer wants to go
f5 which of course also makes some sense
getting some counter play yeah here yeah
this this is just not great I mean after
after the capture
he's got the b-pawn which is much more
dangerous than my C pawn and this
constant knight c6 ideas make the
position really difficult for me after
him after this yeah this is just bad I
have no substantial counter play and
he's got 96 probably lost this
I tried I tried a bit here but there is
nothing nothing to be done check-check
guru gift was a funny move
yes code rook a7 and I resign but this
is also when Jack yeah I always looked
over looked at but it was clear that
even after this the pawns will win the
game
yeah that's just to bear to this
position of the opening okay thanks for
watching